I'm Nolan North and I blame the black
hand of Sauron I'm Troy Baker and I play
tallien and shadow of Mordor we've
worked to put together a few games this
is the first time that we've ever like
really in a performance capture setting
ever been like yeah we've been on other
performance capture games but our two
characters didn't collide when you take
an interactive game to a performance
capture studio it's a completely
different experience for the game and
and and for the actor for the actor you
know and then for him to be able to come
in here and do this great job with the
lead character tallien and then it's so
much fun for me to be able to play the
darker character now I give you no
choice
Shelby shield together in death you know
through social media and through
people's imaginations they envision that
Nolan and I have this huge rivalry which
is ridiculous
which is ridiculous because we're
ridiculous it's good for the game and
keep a straight face yeah we hate each
other it's the worst
the huge epic story you have huge epic
characters and from the black hand to
tylium to Caliburn boards all these
characters have such a crucial thing to
play and one thing that i love
specifically about this character is
what does it look like when a normal man
is an everyday man is in this
supernatural experience and it all
starts with a great story with stuff the
great script and then great characters
all of which we had I have a gift for
you
cannibal
Lord of the Rings was the first like
epic saga that I was ever introduced to
and I remember just staring at the book
and feeling it was like there's volume
one um it was like such a daunting task
you couldn't read not everyone needs to
know that can we cut that out